there is a president erdogan that's
shaking hands of his supporters in
Istanbul are there and he has cast his
vote in this presidential runoff as you
can see on the screen he's looking to
end extend his uh 20 years in power this
is uh run off after the vote a couple of
weeks ago was inconclusive he's of
course fighting the opposition candidate
um there kamalitch Dara Lou let's just
look at these pictures there you can see
the Voting is in process handing over
his vote
yeah
there we are
it is
going in
and there are live pictures from
Istanbul the current leader who's been
in power for two decades now looking to
extend that grip at the heads of turkey
of course turkey a country facing
numerous problems largely to do with the
economy and the plummeting Lira but that
is uh president erdogan who is fighting
to stay on in power he should know by
the end of this evening whether he has
done that this is the presidential
runoff with Mr kilich darelu a former
bureaucrats after the election of two
weeks ago no man secured an overall
majority there so we will see what
happens incidentally the polls close
about three o'clock this afternoon our
time and we'll get a guide a little
later in the evening who in fact has won
this presidential runoff
well let's hear from Skye's special
correspondent Alex Crawford right now
who can bring us more from Istanbul
whatever the outcome is today it's a
pretty historic day for turkey because
it's the first time that the voters have
gone to a second round of a presidential
election it's the first time that one of
the leaders will be elected if he is
elected and there's a new leader for the
first time in 20 years or it's the first
time the current incumbent is re-elected
for the third time so it's a pretty
momentous day for them all across the
country now last time the the first
round of the presidential elections and
the Parliamentary elections there was an
astonishing 87 of the electorate who
turned out to vote if we have a look now
there's been quite a a steady flow of
Voters turning up since the polls opened
at eight o'clock local time in Turkey
this morning and they are a very uh
enthusiastic voters and it doesn't seem
like they're any different this time now
of those 87 electorate last time there
was a substantial number of first-time
voters about 5 million were estimated to
be first-time voters and according to
some of the estimates only half of those
turned out so in the meantime the two
running for election the incumbent
ER erdogan and the opposition the head
of an alliance of opposition groups
have been out on the the campaigns done
really urging people to turn out during
the course of those the last two weeks
of of campaigning the topic has really
focused on first of all the economy
because turkey has been suffering quite
dramatically economically it's the Lira
the Turkish lira hits a record low over
the last few days and there's a lot if
you're talking to people on the ground
there's a lot of of worry and concern
about whoever is elected how the economy
is going to fare with inflation last
year officially topping something like
80 percent but unofficially expected to
be much much higher than that and on the
ground we're talking to
shopkeepers and buyers and just ordinary
people they talk about prices jumping
double triple quadruple so a lot of
people in Turkey really suffering
economically the two people who are
trying to get the electorate to vote for
them
have been trying to Garner votes from
a lot of
parties and groups who are substantially
vote and support the Nationalist
movement there's been a lot of criticism
about both of them uh appealing to the
anti-immigrant section and with about
four million refugees in Turkey they are
according to the UN the largest host of
refugees in the world right now there's
been a lot of unease about how the
campaign the election campaign has swung
towards an anti-immigrant
anti-refugee sentiment and there's a lot
of fear amongst syrians Afghans on the
ground about how that's going to play
out and what the future holds for them
that was Alex Crawford we saw president
erdogan the voting a few minutes ago
this is uh his uh opposition or the only
opposition right now he is facing his
opponent kimal kilich derolu he is
voting in Ankara the capital of Turkey
interesting that
Mr erdogan was in Istanbul but this is
the 74 year old Kamal courage durolu he
has described the runoff taking place
today as a referendum on turkey's future
there he is in Ankara he is up against
Mr erdogan who could remain if he wins
this runoff he could stay in power until
2028 he's already been there for 20
years at 87 of the electorate voted last
time both men are looking to see what
happens to the 8 million or so undecided